ضوء اخضر الماني منتظر لاتاحه ارسال
الدبابات لبرج القتاليه الى اوكرانيا
وبالنظر الى حاله الحرب المستمره منذ ما
يقرب من عام واحد يجب ان نزل جميع
الايجابيات وسلبيات بعنايات فائقه
المانيا والمتحدث باسم حكومتها اشتراط
تقديم واشنطن دبابه القتال الرئيسيه لديها
اموان ابرامز لتوريد هذا الطراز من
الدبابات الا ان الصحفا المانيه عده اكدت
اعتراض المستشار الالماني على اتخاذي
بلاده الخطوه الاولى
الحجام والالماني المتداول عن تقديم
الدبابات ليبرز او السماحي لدول الاخرى
بتزويدها غير مبرر امريكيا لا بل ان
المقارنه بين الدبابتين غير متوازنه وفق
مسؤولين امريكيين فالدببه الالمانيه
متوفره بجميع الدول الاوروبيه وسهله
الاستخدام ولا تسبب عرقله اللوجستيه
وتستلزم ليبرت تدريبا اقل مقارنه بدبابات
ابرامز المكلفه التي تستهلك وقود الطائرات
بمعدل الثلاثه جالونات لكل ميلا واحد كما
تصعب الصيانه المرتبطه بتشغيلها هذا
التركيز على دبابات لبرد الالمانيه الصنع
سببه كذلك امتلاك الحلفاء المئات منها ما
قد يخفف العبء على بلد بعينه فبولاندا
مثلا ترغب بارسال 14 دبابه من هذا الطراز
لكنها تصطدم بمعارضه المانيه واذن مسبق قد
يكون مطلوبا
يذكر انه تم بالفعل ارسال دبابات الى
اوكرانيا لكنها قديمه وتعمل بذخيره من
الحقبه السوفيتيه اوشكت على النفاذه لذلك
ياتي تشديد الرئيس الاوكراني على ضروره
امدادهم بدبابات حديثه تستخدم ذخيره غربيه
اكثر وفره ما يمنحهم قدره ماموله على قلب
الموازين